il existe des murs
d'importance abritant des palais
imposants où s'engouffre des vents
immobiles où ne pénètre jamais le
froid il existe des gens sans
conscience qui signent des décrets
malfaisant et radote des lois
imbéciles
qui balait la raison et le
droit il existe des lieux
d'insolence à l'abri des gueux et des
perdants où se battent des Princes
futiles brûlant des fortunes dans la
joie il existe dans la Douce
France de la mort au milieu des
vivants du désert au mi-temps de la
ville des hivers qui durent 12
mois j'ai vu des regards sans
existence des fantômes qui trompent le
temps des humains au gestes mal
habiles qui mendit devant les
cinémas tout un peuple garde le
silence mais le vacarm est
assourdissant la détresse sans cesse
défile il se blottis sous le moindre
toi
il existe des murs
d'importance abritant des palais
imposants où sengouffre des vents
immobiles où ne pénètre jamais le
roi il existe dans la douce
France de la mort au milieu des
vivants du désert au mi-temps de la
ville des hivers qui durent 12
mois